hey was geht ab jetzt willkommen beim
neuen video ich habe heute mein kumpel
christian dabei ja ich bin ich also
alles braucht ein bisschen schöner nicht
ganz so erfahren sagen wir mal auf
diesem themengebiet auf jeden fall habe
ich euch auf instagram gefragt ja stellt
uns doch mal fragen die ihr so einen
jungs nicht versteht an der art nicht
versteht an der james darstellung
einschätzung irgendwie so mathe und ja
wir würden euch gerne mal so ein
bisschen darüber aufklären bzw was wir
darüber denken wir wünschen euch viel
spaß mit euch gefällt geben auch nach
oben und so im heike 1501 fragt dass
manche jungs lieber reingehen zocken als
draußen zu bleiben ihr also dazu kann
ich nur eines sagen ich weiß noch ganz
genau als wir beide so 12 13
wir sagten ohne scheiß den ganzen tag
bevor unserem computer langsam scheiß
browsergame erzeugt weil wir einfach
süchtig danach waren und ich meine jetzt
bleibe ich auch nicht mehr draußen als
zocken zu gehen ich glaube du bist du an
die süchtigen jungs geraten
aber das geht auch nach
also bei mir schon so christian die
nächste frage ist für dich und zwar
fragt melina stuff warum tragt ihr eure
hosen so tief ja also eigentlich trägt
man ja heutzutage nicht nativ oder also
ich trage schon noch tief ich weiß nicht
warum aber ich finde das cool aus als
wird man nicht so richtig kennt ihr
diese jungs die ihre hosen bisher haben
sie aus als wären die weinig traum seit
ich schreibe meine kommentare befindet
so diskriminiert es gibt ja verschiedene
anfangs das magische lagen mit den hoch
machen
beim letzten video weißt wie du nicht
auseinander genommen hast das finde ich
halte das für die scheiße aber schreibe
die kommentare zu den gesprächen klingt
so du bist ja du bist erst die nächsten
tage ich einzige hier geht es also
instagram mir eingebildet dass wenn man
einen freund hat er immer anderen frauen
hinterher gucken warum ist das so also
einwohnern also also eigentlich kann man
sagen das liegt in der jungs gene aber
eigentlich macht man sowas nicht oder
also man sollte es natürlich nicht
machen ebene seiten man will zb freundin
verärgern damit man will sie mobben
man will die bisher in new york ist es
vertretbar der euch aus durchaus des
islam fragt warum dreht sich viel um
fischerei und das liegt einmal daran
weil jung ist einfach der hammer jeder
junge markt fußball und fifa ist cool
weil der hype wird von jahr zu jahr
größer und immer so zwei monate bevor
peter auskommen da geht an der schule
schon solo single komm kiefer ich komme
nicht mehr zur schule und so hat das
sagen willst du dazu doch etwas
beitragen also wie gesagt vieles einfach
mein leben sein leben unser leben ich
bin jetzt nicht so der extreme fifa
zucker schlecht automatisch an uhr fifa
12 hat jetzt auch mal schnell die letzte
frage nicht mal bord ist die annoncen
society fragt dass die nicht das mädchen
das immer für sie da ist
ich bin das gab wirklich unbeschreiblich
traurig weil ich würde das mädchen was
für mich da ist weil wir zum 15
ruft opitz im kopf zu ruhig kommen die
top 10
wir können mit bronze ich sag mal so man
kann sich ja nicht aussuchen in dem man
sich verliebt es liegt jetzt nicht
unbedingt immer darin ob jetzt immer für
einen da ist oder nicht es gibt
natürlich auch ganz viele unglücksfälle
und wenn jetzt eine mädchen immer für
einen da ist und vielleicht auch ein
bisschen auf 1 steht man selber aber
nichts von ihr will dann hängt das werk
ganz wenig dann ergibt das ganze ja
überhaupt keinen sinn
oder habe ich würde sagen wenn sie
wirklich immer für ihn da ist guck mal
das heißt ja sie hilft ihnen auch und
wenn sie sich gegenseitig helfen dann
kann schon ernste beziehung kommen
das ist richtig
was wie wir das also liebe leute deshalb
denkt nummer 3 das war's doch leider
schon wieder mit break nummer vier das
wasser kleidergeld der mal witzig da
weiß irgendwann nicht mehr auf jeden
fall wenn es euch gefallen hat wenn ihr
mehr mit ihm sehen wollte wenn ihr uns
recht geht oder so dann gebt einfach den
daumen nach oben hier findet ihr sei
instagram profil eingeblendet check up
und hier natürlich mainz und ja
ansonsten aber nie vergessen wenn nicht
mehr verpassen wollt in der video
beschreibung twitter facebook und co
alles noch mal schön aufgeschrieben auf
ersten seite also hier so links jetzt
weiter mit meinen letzten video glaub
ich ein paar klamotten vorgestellt ich
eingekauft habe und hier auf der rechten
seite mit irgendeinem anderen videos und
wie sie muss dann in einer woche wie
schon am mittwoch papiers ferien und so